alegría en la sede del partido Colorado
aquí en Asunción por una victoria
holgada de Santiago Peña sobre su
contrincante Frank alegre que pierde por
tercera vez las elecciones esta vez con
un elemento nuevo la irrupción de
paraguayos Cuba el candidato antisistema
que capitalizado el descontento de una
parte de la población consiguiendo un
resultado espectacular hoy hemos pasado
por varios colegios electorales y
personas de diferentes edades nos decían
que no se sienten representados por
ninguno de los dos partidos hegemónicos
y que querían un cambio sin embargo este
cambio no se ha visto
reflejado en las urnas la mayoría de los
paraguayos ha elegido la continuidad no
solo con el partido Colorado sino
también con el modelo de Horacio cartes
que es el presidente del partido
recordamos que cartes ha sido declarado
corrupto por el gobierno de los Estados
Unidos y que Santiago Peña le ha alabado
en su discurso nada más su Victoria todo
apunta a que Horacio Carter seguirá
gobernando en la sombra porque sabemos
que Peña es su delfín también se decían
las últimas semanas que el gobierno de
Maiden podría pedir la extradición de
cartes por sus delitos que también están
en el suelo norteamericano sin embargo
parece muy difícil ese escenario ahora
es el momento de celebrar para aquellos
votantes que han elegido al partido
Colorado
Santiago Peña tiene hasta el 15 de
agosto para preparar la transición y
Entonces será el nuevo presidente de
Paraguay